COYOTES, BIG LAWSON CROUSE GOING
UP AGAINST KASSIAN, IT WILL APP.
BIG NIGHT AGAINST THE DUCKS ON
TUESDAY I
BACK COME THE COYOTES ANOTHER
WAY.
BEAUTIFUL PLAY.
BANK PASS OF
STRALMAN FOR A LARSSON, BACK IT
THE LINES AND IS STOPPED
BY VEJMELKA.
>> Tyson: THAT'S A BIG STOP AND
A SAVE YOU.
>> Matt: OUT OF THE ZONE IT
ICING CALL.
>> Tyson:
LEAD PASS INTENDED FOR TRAVIS CT
HERE IN THE OPENING PERIOD.
NICE MOVE THERE BY CHYCHRUN
OPPORTUNITY.
KOSKINEN SHUT IN.
ANDREW LADD ALL OVER IT.
ONG TIME.
>> Matt: ASSISTANT CAPTAIN WITH
THE ROADRUNNERS AS WELL. PERLIN.
.
NOW BEHIND THE NET.
LARSSON, AROUND FOR KELLER NOW.K
DAVID AND
FISCHER DENIED AND CLEARED MOME.
DEVIN SHORE FELL ON HIM IN A
FAN ON THE GROUND IT WAS
SCHMALTZ.
>> Tyson: OH, NICK SCHMALTZ HE
CA PRESSURE,
BACK-TO-BACK POWER PLAYS FOOT
COYOTES AND
DRAISAITL AND McDAVID COYOTE.
>> Matt: BACK OUT HIGH IT GOES,
McDAVID.
HOW
HIM.
RYAN LOOKS IT GETKASSIAN.
LYUBUSHKIN.
NOW BACK TO THE FRONT.
THEY CAN'T FINISH ITFENDING ON T
SHIFT WHAT IE COYOTES HAVE THEIT
IT. NO
A SHOT AND IT BOUNCES COMES BAC.
RI GAME.
THE WAY THEY MOVE THE PUCK MAN,.
2:25.
AND WATCH, THENS IS THERE.
>> Tyson: NOW THE ENTIRE
TIGHTENING U
HAD ONE SHORTHANDED, NOW HE HAS
ONE ON THE POWER PLAY,
McDAVID, HE KNOWS
THERE.
A CHANCE TO GET THAT
UP HIGH, GIVE HIM A